This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You're sitting in a school bus next to your best friend. She tells you about the time she stole an eraser from the teacher's desk. You wonder whether you should tell her about the time you stole a plush toy from a store. As the bus rolls along, you go back and forth in your mind and then decide against it. A few years later, you're at your high school prom. At the end of the evening, you should. share a kiss with your prom date, who turns out to have bad breath.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你坐在校车里，紧挨着你最好的朋友。她告诉你她曾经从老师的桌子上偷过一块橡皮。你纳闷自己是否该告诉她，你曾经从商店里偷过一个毛绒玩具。随着校车向前开动，你在心里反来复去地盘算，最后决定还是不说了。几年后，你正参加高中毕业舞会。在舞会快结束时，你应该和舞伴接吻，结果却发现对方有口臭。
This is not someone you are interested in long term. Do you share the information or withhold it? Or consider a much more serious situation later in life? You're in a long-term relationship, and you realize that for some years now, you have been questioning your own sexual orientation. Your partner would be crushed to hear about it. Things are generally going well in your relationship, and you don't have immediate plans to act on your secret feelings.
这不是你想要长期交往的对象。你会把这事说出来还是隐瞒？或者想想生活中后来遇到的更严重的情况？你处于一段长期恋爱关系中，你意识到从几年前开始，你就在质疑自己的性取向。如果听到这个，你的伴侣会心碎的。你们的关系总体进展顺利，而且你也没有马上将内心的秘密付诸行动的打算。
Is it best to keep them to yourself? At every stage of life, we find ourselves confronted with dilemmas like this. There is a part of us that wants to share, to have the world see us as we truly are, and there is a part of us that sees how people are brought down by scandal and gossip. And a cautious voice inside us says, Be smart. Keep your mouth shut. In today's show and our episode next week, and also in a special episode of Hidden Brain Plus,
把这些藏在心里是最好的选择吗？在人生的各个阶段，我们都会发现自己面临这样的两难境地。我们内心有一部分渴望分享，渴望让世界看到我们最真实的模样；而另一部分则看到了人们是如何被丑闻和流言蜚语击垮的。我们内心一个谨慎的声音说：聪明点，闭紧你的嘴。在今天的节目、我们下周的专集，以及《隐藏的大脑·升级版》的一期特别节目中，
we explore the psychological costs and benefits of self-concealment and self-disclosure. Keeping Secrets, this week on Hidden Brain. In the course of a day, countless thoughts and feelings enter our minds. We share some of these thoughts and feelings with others, but we keep most of them to ourselves. When is it smart to share? When is it smart to hide? Is there scientific evidence that can guide us on what we should do? At Harvard University, psychologist Leslie John has spent many years studying these questions.
我们将探讨自我隐瞒和自我披露的心理成本与收益。《保守秘密》，本周《隐藏的大脑》。在一天当中，无数的想法和感受涌入我们的脑海。我们与他人分享其中一些想法和感受，但把大部分都留给了自己。什么时候分享是明智的？什么时候隐瞒是明智的？有没有科学证据能指导我们该怎么做？在哈佛大学，心理学家莱斯利·约翰花了很多时间研究这些问题。
Leslie, John, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar. Leslie, one of your favorite TV programs is the British comedy series, Mr. Bean. There's one particular episode that you enjoy, and for people who are unfamiliar with the show, who is Mr. Bean and what is he doing in this scene? I love Mr. Bean. Mr. Bean is a comic mime, I would say, and his sweet spot is he finds these very relatable human situations, these quandaries we get ourselves in. And then he comes up with absurd, almost childlike solutions. So it's a really, really endearing and hilarious show. And also brings me back to my childhood because my father and I are the jokers of the family. And we're We are huge Mr. Bean fans. So in this particular little sketch, Mr. Bean goes to a fancy schmancy restaurant and orders steak tartar doesn't realize that that's essentially raw meat.
莱斯利·约翰，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。莱斯利，你最喜欢的电视节目之一是英国喜剧系列剧《憨豆先生》。你特别喜欢其中一集，对于不熟悉这部剧的观众来说，憨豆先生是谁？他在这个场景里在做什么？我超爱憨豆先生。我想憨豆先生是一位喜剧哑剧演员，他的拿手好戏是捕捉那些非常接地气的人类处境、我们经常陷入的困境。然后他会想出荒诞、近乎孩子气的解决方案。所以这是一部非常非常讨人喜欢、让人捧腹大笑的剧。这也勾起了我的童年回忆，因为我和我父亲是家里的活宝。我们都是憨豆先生的超级粉丝。所以在这一小段滑稽短剧里，憨豆先生去了一家极其高档的餐厅，点了一份鞑靼牛排，却没有意识到那基本上是生肉。
And so the waiter comes out with his meal with great flare, opens up the silver closh that's on top of the plate and to Mr. Bean's horror, like his face. He says it all. He's completely aghast. What have I done? But yet, the waiter, you know, the waiter, of course, assholes it doing. Is everything all right, sir? And Mr. Bean does this, like his smiley. Oh, yes, everything is great. Oh, yes. And then the waiter leaves. And then what Mr. Bean proceeds to do is grab little dollops of the steak, of the raw meat, and put it wherever he can to get rid of it. because you have to follow through with the lie, right? You have to show progress on eating it.
于是服务员风度翩翩地端着他的餐点出来，打开了盘子上面的银色圆盖，呈现在憨豆先生眼前的是——就像他的表情一样。他把一切都写在了脸上。他完全惊呆了。我干了什么？然而，服务员，你知道的，服务员当然不知道他在干什么。一切都好吗，先生？而憨豆先生就这样，挤出一个微笑。哦，是的，一切都很好。哦，是的。然后服务员离开了。接着，憨豆先生开始做的事情是，抓起一小团一小团的牛排、生肉，把它塞到任何能塞的地方以摆脱它。因为你得把这个谎演下去，对吧？你得表现出你在吃它、在吃东西的样子。
So, yeah, so he, like, puts a little bit in the fuzz, and then he leans back, and he puts a little bit in the woman's purse behind him. He hollows out, he hollows out a dinner roll and shoves it in. And then he even takes a dollop, sticks it directly on the table, and sticks the plate to it, like cement. So good. I understand that you had your own Mr. Bean moment some years ago. Can you set the scene for me and tell me what happened?
所以，对，他就把一小块塞进花瓶里，然后往后一靠，把一小块塞进他身后女人的钱包里。他掏空，掏空了一个餐包，然后把肉塞了进去。甚至还抓了一团，直接粘在桌子上，把盘子像水泥一样粘在上面。太绝了。据我所知，几年前你也有过属于自己的“憨豆先生”时刻。你能为我还原一下当时的场景，告诉我发生了什么吗？
Yeah, so I was a baby academic and I was invited out to give a talk at Berkeley. So totally swoon-worthy place. And two superstar scholars invited me out. They're married and they invited me out to their house for dinner after the day. And so here I am, this googly-eyed, junior. your academic, walking through the Berkeley Hills, walking to their house. I get there. And they open the door and they say, oh, we are so excited you're here. We went to the market today and we're making steak tart tar. It's our favorite. It's so special and we only want to do the most
对，当时我刚当上学者不久，受邀去伯克利做个演讲。那可是一个完全让人神往的地方。两位超级巨星级别的学者邀请了我。他们是一对夫妻，那天活动结束后，他们邀请我到他们家吃晚饭。所以当时的我，就是这样一个满眼放光、初出茅庐的青年学者，走在伯克利的丘陵间，步行去他们家。我到了那里。他们打开门说，哦，我们太高兴你能来了。我们今天去了市场，我们在做鞑靼牛排。这是我们的最爱。这非常特别，我们只想为你做最
special things for you. They laid it on thick. And yeah, so I was like, oh my gosh, I want to be Mr. Mean right now. I want to do what he does. But obviously I couldn't. So, So I pretended. I was too ashamed, embarrassed, trying to make a good impression, trying to pretend I like highfalutin things, and I ate it. I got through it. In fact, I've never told them this. So maybe they'll hear this and we'll have a good laugh over it. But, yeah, that was my Mr. Bean moment. So concealment can sometimes have bigger consequences, Leslie. You tell the story of two women you know. You call them Jennifer and Donna. When the story starts, Jennifer is preparing for an important event in her life.
特别的事情。他们话说得挺满。所以，对，当时我就想：天哪，我此刻就想当憨豆先生。我想做他做的事。但显然我不能。所以，所以我假装吃了。我当时太羞愧、太尴尬了，只想留下好印象，极力假装自己喜欢高雅的事物，于是我把它吃下去了。我硬着头皮吃完了。事实上，我从来没跟他们说过这事。所以也许他们听到这个节目后，我们会拿这事开怀大笑一番。不过，是的，那就是我的“憨豆先生”时刻。所以隐瞒有时会带来更大的后果，莱斯利。你讲过你认识的两个女人的故事。你称她们为詹妮弗和唐娜。故事开始时，詹妮弗正在为她人生中的一个重要事件做准备。
Paint a picture of the scene for me, Leslie. Yeah, so Jennifer was about 28 years old, and she was on the cusp of a major life milestone. The next month, she was slated to marry her betrothed, her fiancé Philip. The only thing was that she was starting to get, these kind of nagging thoughts, these nagging doubts. And she didn't know, are these just like normal wedding jitters? Is that a thing? Or is this something I should pay more attention to? So she was really close with her mother, Donna, and she decided to give her mom a call. And so the phone,
请为我描绘一下当时的场景，莱斯利。好的，当时詹妮弗大约28岁，她正处于人生一个重大里程碑的边缘。第二个月，她预定要嫁给她的挚爱、未婚夫菲利普。唯一的问题是，她开始产生一种挥之不去的想法，这种挥之不去的疑虑。她不知道，这只是正常的婚前焦虑吗？真的有这种东西吗？还是说这是我应该多加关注的问题？她跟母亲唐娜非常亲近，于是她决定给妈妈打个电话。于是电话，
as the phone rings, Jennifer is transported back to her childhood home where her parents still lived. And, you know, she's thinking about the living room where she and her brothers would do WWF wrestling matches. And then she thinks about the den where she envisions her mom to be at that time, sitting cozyed up in the den with its faux wood paneling walls and all. And then suddenly, hello. And Jennifer says, hi, mom, it's me. Donna immediately senses something's up and says, what's up, my mom? chick. And then Jennifer said to her mother, well, you know, I just, I don't know about these feelings I'm having. And when I think about it, I really love Philip, but I love him like my best friend.
随着电话铃响，詹妮弗被带回了她父母至今仍居住的童年老家。你知道，她想起了她和哥哥们曾在那儿进行世界摔角娱乐（WWF）比赛的客厅。然后她想到了书房，她脑海中浮现出当时妈妈坐在书房里的温馨模样，书房里到处都是仿木镶板的墙壁。接着突然，喂。詹妮弗说：嗨，妈妈，是我。唐娜立刻觉察到不对劲，说道：怎么啦，我的小宝贝？然后詹妮弗对妈妈说：嗯，你知道的，我只是，我不知道自己现在的这些感受是怎么回事。当我想起这事时，我真的很爱菲利普，但我对他的爱就像对最好的朋友那样。
And I don't know that I have like passionate love for him. And I don't know, is that a problem? Because I, I really love him in a best friend kind of way. And Donna listened. And then Jennifer said, Mom, how did you know that you wanted to marry dad? Because Jennifer always looked up to their marriage so much. They just seemed like they were amazing parents and they just seemed so happy. And that's all that Jennifer wanted was a really stable, loving, wonderful relationship. And her mom said, huh, it's funny, Jen, that you should ask because a month before I married your father, I was actually having similar doubts.
我不知道自己对他有没有那种充满激情的爱。我不知道，这算是个问题吗？因为我，我确实是以对待挚友的方式深爱着他。唐娜听着。接着詹妮弗说：妈妈，你怎么知道你想嫁给爸爸的？因为詹妮弗一直非常崇拜他们的婚姻。他们看起来就像是了不起的父母，而且他们看起来那么幸福。詹妮弗想要的全部，就是一段真正稳定、充满爱意、美好的关系。她的妈妈说：哼，真有意思，詹，你居然会问这个，因为就在我嫁给你父亲的前一个月，我其实也有过类似的疑虑。
And, oh, I'm so glad I went ahead with Miriam because look how happy we are. Look at how great our marriage is. We work. And she said, like, Jen, I know you. You're like me. You struggle to make decisions. You ruminate. You question everything.
而且，哦，我太高兴我最终还是跟你爸结婚了，因为你看我们多幸福。你看我们的婚姻多美满。我们很合拍。她说，詹，我了解你。你就像我一样。你很难做决定。你会反复琢磨。你质疑一切。
But sometimes you just, if it feels right, you've got to go with it. And so Jennifer took a lot of comfort in that phone call. and what she thought was, yeah, I already have, my love with Philip is already the mature kind, you know, passionate love fades. What's really special and important is the mature kind, the kind that my mother has always had with my father. And so a month later, Jennifer and Philip were married. Five very complicated years later, they were divorced. So sometime after her divorce, Jennifer's brother sends her an email that changed. changes, everything. What's in this email, Leslie?
但有时你就是，如果感觉对了，你就得顺其自然。所以詹妮弗从那通电话里得到了极大的安慰。她当时想，是的，我已经有了，我对菲利普的爱已经是成熟的那种了，你知道的，激情的爱会消逝。真正特殊且重要的是成熟的爱，那种我母亲和我父亲一直拥有的爱。于是，一个月后，詹妮弗和菲利普结婚了。五年错综复杂的婚姻生活过后，他们离婚了。所以在她离婚后的一段时间里，詹妮弗的哥哥给她发了一封邮件，这封邮件改变了，改变了一切。这封邮件里写了什么，莱斯利？
Yeah. It was an email chain that originated between Donna and her husband. So it was a private between the two of them. And they ended up, what they started talking about was a very private sensitive thing. But where they ended up in the email chain was talking about finances. And they brought Jennifer's brother. At this point, they added the brother to the email chain because the brother took care of their finances. And so then the brother forwards this to Jennifer. So Jennifer's sitting down in her bachelor's pat. She's got her lovely coffee in the morning. She's sitting down. She opens her inbox. And she gets this email from her brother. Hey, Jen, check this out. Seems like they forgot. What was at the beginning of the chain? And so, of course, Jennifer quickly scrolls, scrolls down, down, down. And
对。这是一封最初在唐娜和她丈夫之间往来的邮件链。所以这是他们两人之间的私事。他们最终，他们开始谈论的是一件非常私密、敏感的事情。但他们在邮件链中最后谈到的却是财务问题。他们把詹妮弗的哥哥也拉了进来。此时，他们把哥哥加到了邮件链中，因为哥哥帮他们理财。于是哥哥就把这封邮件转发给了詹妮弗。所以詹妮弗正坐在她的单身公寓里。她早上捧着心爱的咖啡。她坐下来。她打开收件箱。然后她收到了哥哥发来的这封邮件。嘿，詹，看看这个。看来他们忘了。这邮件链开头是什么内容？所以，当然，詹妮弗赶紧往下滚动、滚动、滚动，然后
wow, what she found out, she can never unknown. and it's the kind of thing that is extremely shocking for someone to learn about their parents. What the initial exchange revealed was that Donna and her husband had had an unusual relationship. It worked for them. It was an open relationship of sorts. And they were discussing that in the chain in a very amicable way. Like it was clear that it was a mutual agreement. It was and it was one that really worked for them and they even celebrated it.
哇，她发现的事情，是永远无法当作不知道的。这就是那种让一个人在得知自己父母的事情时感到极其震惊的内容。最初的对话透露出，唐娜和她的丈夫维持着一种不同寻常的关系。这种关系对他们很管用。可以说是一种开放式关系。而且他们在邮件链中非常友好地讨论着这一点。就像很清楚这是一个共同的协议。而且这是一个真正适合他们的协议，他们甚至为此庆祝。
You could tell in this email chain. So I mean, Jennifer was a very open-minded person and she thought, wow, that's shocking. But you do you. And if that works for you, great. But the more dominant feeling that Jennifer had, her whole body filled with anger and rage. Like, you know when you feel it super viscerally, that is how Jennifer felt. Because immediately she goes back in time in her mind to that fateful call that was, you know, seven or so years ago between her mother, Donna and herself, the pre-wedding jitters call.
你从这封邮件链中能看出来。所以我的意思是，詹妮弗是一个思想很开放的人，她当时想：哇，这太令人震惊了。不过走你自己的路吧。如果这适合你们，那就太好了。但詹妮弗内心占据主导的感受却是，她全身充满了愤怒和狂怒。就像你知道那种内心深处翻江倒海的感觉一样，詹妮弗就是这种感觉。因为她立刻在脑海中回到了当年那通命运般的电话——大约是七年前或更早，在她母亲唐娜和她自己之间进行的、关于婚前焦虑的电话。
And how Jennifer had felt so assuaged. And Jennifer felt that Donna's words really, really did affect that decision. And the reason Jennifer was filled with rage, because she was. she said to herself, wait, mom, you only told me half the truth. You didn't tell me that the way you're kind of escape valve, the way you handle this fact that you have people that you, shall I say, enjoy your flirtations with maybe more than her father, was by having this release valve, this mutual agreement. And this would have been extremely pertinent for Jennifer to have known because Jennifer was quite
以及詹妮弗当时感到是多么的安心。詹妮弗觉得唐娜的话确实、确实影响了那个决定。詹妮弗之所以满腔怒火，是因为她，她对自己说：等等，妈妈，你只告诉我了一半的真相。你没有告诉我，你的某种“逃生阀”、你处理这种事实的方式——也就是你有那些，我可以说，你享受调情的人，也许比她父亲更多的人——是通过这种释放阀、这种共同协议来解决的。而这对于詹妮弗来说，是极其相关且必须知道的信息，因为詹妮弗当时非常
certain at that time that if she had known the full picture of, of what her parents' relationship was, she would not have married Philip because she knew that although that worked for them, she knew it wouldn't work for her, and that's not what she wanted. And so she really felt like, kind of betrayed by her mother.
确信，如果她当时知道了父母关系的完整全貌，她是不会嫁给菲利普的，因为她知道，尽管这种模式适合他们，但她知道这不适合她，那不是她想要的生活。所以她真的觉得自己被母亲背叛了。
And she felt like it would have been better if her mother had said nothing, if her mother hadn't even picked up the phone, than to share only half the story. Yeah, because Jennifer, in some ways, got comfort from what her mother was saying, but her mother in some ways was not sharing that the terms of her relationship with her husband involved seeing other people. And there was, as you say, a release valve in this marriage.
她觉得，如果她母亲什么都不说，如果她母亲当时根本没接那个电话，也总比只分享一半的故事要好。是的，因为詹妮弗在某种程度上从母亲的话中得到了安慰，但她的母亲在某种程度上却隐瞒了她与丈夫关系的条款中包含与其他人的交往。而且，正如你所说，这段婚姻里有一个释放阀。
Exactly. Did Jennifer ever confront Donna about what she had said previously? Yes, she did. So years later, Jennifer, her anger faded because everything who turned out beautifully for her, She married the man of her dream. She married her Prince Charming who was, she was attracted to in all ways. They had two beautiful children. Like she was just living a slice of paradise.
没错。詹妮弗有没有当面质问过唐娜关于她以前说过的话？是的，她质问过。所以多年后，詹妮弗的愤怒消退了，因为一切对她来说结果美满。她嫁给了梦寐以求的男子。她嫁给了她的白马王子，一个她在各方面都深深被其吸引的人。他们有了两个漂亮的孩子。她简直就像生活在人间仙境里。
She was so happy, which made it easier for the old wounds to kind of heal. But they were replaced by curiosity and wanting to learn more. How did this start? Why did it start? Is it ever complicated? So one day, Grandma Donna was visiting and Jennifer's husband was, husband was out of town. So Jennifer's like, this is like, she had a good workout during the day. She's like, I can do this. Let's do it. And after dinner pours two, two large, large glasses of scotch.
她太幸福了，这让旧伤更容易愈合。但愤怒被好奇心和想要了解更多的渴望所取代。这一切是怎么开始的？为什么要开始？这其中难道没有复杂性吗？所以有一天，外婆唐娜来串门，詹妮弗的丈夫外出了。于是詹妮弗想：就是现在，她白天刚健过身，心想：我行，我可以。吃过晚饭后，她倒了两杯、两大杯苏格兰威士忌。
There is such a thing as liquid courage, sits down with her mom and says, do you remember that phone call we had before my first marriage? and Donna said like a wave of warmth, like motherly warmth smile came across her face and she said, yeah, I do. And I've often wondered whether I said the right thing. And that was just the perfect segue in. And then what proceeded was probably the most meaningful conversation Jennifer had had definitely with her mother, potentially with anyone ever. And so that just really, really ended up a deep in their relationship. All of us make choices in nearly every moment of our lives about what to share with others and what to keep private. These decisions have consequences for our health, our well-being, and our relationships.
这世上确实有“借酒壮胆”这回事，她跟妈妈坐在一起说：还记得我第一次结婚前我们打的那通电话吗？唐娜就像一阵暖流、母爱的暖流一样的微笑浮现在脸上，说道：记得，我当然记得。而且我经常纳闷，自己当时说的话到底对不对。这简直是绝佳的切入时机。接下来发生的，大概是詹妮弗一生中——绝对是跟母亲之间，也可能是跟任何人之间——最有意义的一次对话。所以这最终真正、真正加深了他们之间的关系。我们所有人在生活的几乎每个瞬间都在做选择：什么该与他人分享，什么该作为秘密保留。这些决定对我们的健康、幸福以及人际关系都有着深远的影响。
When we come back, the psychology of self-concealment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Leslie John is a psychologist at Harvard Business School. She studies self-concealment and self-disclosure. Leslie, most of us are keenly aware of the dangers of oversharing. We've all heard stories about someone who, you know, posted a photo of themselves at a drunken frat party,
稍后回来，我们将探讨自我隐瞒的心理学。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。莱斯利·约翰是哈佛商学院的心理学家。她研究自我隐瞒和自我披露。莱斯利，我们大多数人都敏锐地意识到了过度分享的危险。我们都听过这样的故事：某人，你知道的，在醉酒兄弟会派对上发了张照片，
and then they got turned down for a job years later. Talk for a moment about this. Our default position is often, when in doubt, say nothing. Yes. You can think of even those sayings from wartime. Loose lips sink ships, right? It feels like the default, The strong default we have is to stay silent if there's any doubt.
结果几年后求职被拒。能聊聊这个吗？我们的默认立场往往是：拿不准的时候，什么也别说。是的。你甚至可以想想二战时期的那些标语。“大嘴招祸”，对吧？感觉我们的默认行为、根深蒂固的默认行为就是：如果有任何疑问，就保持沉默。
And to your point, I mean, the public discourse is kind of obsessed with TMI moments, right, of outing people. That's TMI. That's oversharing. And it is true. Of course we can share too much at the wrong time with the wrong people. It can bite us in all these ways. But what I found in our research is that we don't pay attention. We don't pay enough attention to the other side of the coin, which is what I call T-L-I-2. too little information and that there are very real harms to not opening up, to staying silent.
正如你所说，公众舆论似乎对“TMI”（信息过载）时刻、对公开曝光他人有着某种痴迷，对吧？那是TMI。那是过度分享。确实如此。我们当然会在错误的时间对错误的人分享太多。这会在各种方面反噬我们。但在我们的研究中，我发现我们没有给予关注。我们没有对硬币的另一面给予足够的关注，我称之为“TLI”——
And so I'm hoping that we can start adjudicating these decisions of whether to share or not in a more balanced, even-handed way where we consider both TMI and TLI. Let's look at some of the ways in which concealment can hurt us. You've talked about some shocking research into how much information people hide from their own doctors. Oh, yeah. So there's some fascinating research by some scholars in the medical area where they have asked, interviewed patients essentially whether they've hid some really pertinent health information from their doctor, right? The very person who has taken an oath to protect them.
太少的信息（Too Little Information），即不敞开心扉、保持沉默其实会带来非常真实的危害。因此，我希望我们能以一种更平衡、更公正的方式来裁决这些“分享还是隐瞒”的决定，既考虑TMI，也考虑TLI。让我们来看看隐瞒伤害我们的几种方式。你谈到了一些令人震惊的研究，关于人们对自己的医生隐瞒了多少信息。哦，是的。医学领域的学者做过一些非常迷人的研究，他们基本上是询问、采访患者是否曾向医生隐瞒过一些非常相关的健康信息，对吧？而这个人可是发过誓要保护他们的。
And it's 80% of people admit to not being forthcoming, to hiding something from their physicians. And it's super relatable, right? But it's also bananas, on another hand, right? Because this person could help you. But it's understandable because health stuff is often so sensitive. Yeah. And, you know, someone is, you know, trying to quit smoking, for example, and their doctor has been urging them to quit smoking for a number of years.
有80%的人承认自己不够坦诚，对医生隐瞒了某些事情。这太让人感同身受了，对吧？但另一方面，这也很荒谬，对吧？因为这个人本来可以帮到你。不过这也合情合理，因为健康方面的事情往往极其敏感。是的。而且，比如说有人正试图戒烟，而他们的医生多年来一直敦促他们戒烟。
But they've, in fact, been sneaking a couple of cigarettes. So they're trying to drink a little less. But they haven't been successful. It's hard to come clean and tell you a doctor this is what's actually going on in my life. It really is. I had this really funny moment in college where I went to the clinic to get it. I wanted an STD test and I get to the clinic and I was so impressed because when you get there, they let you write down what your issue is. So you never have to say the words out loud. So I wrote it down on the sheet of paper. I handed it in. But then when it was my turn, this is like a Larry David episode, when it was my turn. The nurse said, Leslie John, SDD testing. Nightmare. You tell the story of a physician named John Cullen, who was literally about to cut open a patient to take out their appendix,
但事实上他们一直在偷偷抽几根烟。或者他们正试图少喝点酒。但他们没有成功。要坦白并告诉医生这才是你生活中真实发生的事情，这太难了。确实如此。我在大学时经历过一个非常搞笑的时刻，当时我去诊所检查。我想要做性病（STD）检测，我到了诊所，觉得印象深刻，因为你到那儿时，他们让你写下你的问题是什么。所以你永远不必大声说出那些字眼。于是我把它写在了一张纸上。我交了上去。但后来轮到我的时候——这就像是《宋飞正传》里的情节——轮到我的时候。护士说：莱斯利·约翰，性病检测。简直是噩梦。你讲过一个名叫约翰·卡伦（John Cullen）的医生的故事，他当时正准备切开一个患者的肚子来切除阑尾，
but then realized that the patient may, in fact, not have appendicitis after all. Yeah, this is the, like, a super grand poohba. That's in the American Academy of Family Physicians President, Dr. John Cullen. Maybe that's what made it a little bit harder, actually, because he was so high status. At any rate, he was literally about to cut open a patient to take out their appendix. But he had this kind of sixth sense that something, you know, you do enough reps of these things and you get a sixth sense and something wasn't right. And apparently symptoms of drug abuse, specifically methamphetamines, they can actually resemble those of appendicitis. And so before he cut her open, Dr. Collar gave it one final chance.
但随后意识到这个患者实际上可能根本没有阑尾炎。是的，这位可是大人物。他是美国美国家庭医师学会（American Academy of Family Physicians）的主席，约翰·卡伦医生。也许正是因为他地位太高，事情反而变得更棘手了。无论如何，他当时正准备切开患者的肚子来切除阑尾。但他有一种第六感，觉得有些不对劲——你知道的，这种手术做多了，你就会培养出一种第六感，觉得哪里不对劲。显然，吸毒的症状，特别是甲基苯丙胺（冰毒）的症状，实际上会与阑尾炎的症状相似。所以在动刀之前，卡伦医生给了最后一次机会。
He said, I quote, we're about to cut you open here. Are you sure you don't want to tell me anything else? Finally the patient fessed up and the surgery was aborted. I mean, it's kind of incredible, isn't it? People are willing to have themselves cut open instead of revealing something that they think is shameful. Yeah. Yeah. You also tell another hospital story, this one involving a patient who was bleeding uncontrollably during surgery?
他说，我引述一下：我们马上就要给你动手术了。你确定没有什么别的事想告诉我吗？最后患者终于招了，手术取消了。我的天，这简直不可思议，不是吗？人们宁愿挨刀子，也不愿透露他们认为羞耻的事情。没错。没错。你还讲了另一个医院的故事，这次是一个在手术中无法控制出血的患者？
Yes, this one's even more shocking because it was a life-threatening situation. So before the surgery, the surgeon asks the patient, you know, are you taking any medication? and the patient says no. And then the surgeon comes out to the waiting room just before he's about to operate and says to the mom, are you sure she's not taking anything? Again, the surgeon had kind of a sixth sentence. And then the mother said, nope, nothing. Finally, the surgeon asked again and is imploring her to be honest.
是的，这个故事更令人震惊，因为这是一个危及生命的紧急情况。所以在手术前，外科医生问患者：你知道，你在吃什么药吗？患者说没有。然后外科医生在准备动手术前走到候诊室，对妈妈说：你确定她没吃什么药吗？同样，外科医生有一种第六感。然后母亲说：没有，什么都没吃。最后，外科医生再次询问并恳求她诚实相告。
Please, please, this is your daughter's life. And finally, and it wasn't even the daughter that revealed this. It was her mother that finally revealed that the, the, child, the daughter, the grown daughter was taking weight loss supplements, but of course was too ashamed to say so. And I guess that interferes with bleeding or something. And that literally saved her life. The surgeon ran back in. It was that serious. So it's really, it's very real. The shame we feel around opening up. The apprehension, the worry that someone's going to judge us is a very, very real concern. Because look at the lengths people go to to avoid it.
求求你，求求你，这是你女儿的命啊。最后——甚至都不是女儿自己透露的。是她的母亲最终透露，这个孩子、这个女儿、这个成年女儿一直在服用减肥补充剂，但当然是因为太害羞而不敢说。我猜这会干扰凝血功能什么的。这简直救了她的命。外科医生立刻跑了回去。情况就是这么严重。所以这是非常真实存在的。我们对敞开心扉感到的羞耻。那种畏惧、担心别人会评判我们的忧虑，是一个非常非常真实的顾虑。看看人们为了避免这种情况会付出多大的代价。
Besides complicating our medical care when we don't share things with our doctors, I understand there's research showing that secrecy negatively affects our immune functioning? Yes. When you keep a secret, one of the tricky things is that your mind is very active. Keeping a secret is not an inner activity. It's not a neutral thing. Yet we often think that that's a neutral thing, right? We think that not sharing is neutral.
除了在我们对医生有所隐瞒时让医疗护理变得复杂之外，据我所知，还有研究表明保密会对我们的免疫功能产生负面影响？是的。当你保守秘密时，棘手的事情之一就是你的大脑非常活跃。保守秘密绝不是一种内在的静止状态。它不是一件中立的事。然而我们经常认为这是一件中立的事，对吧？我们认为不分享是中立的。
But in fact, it can be an incredibly active process. So when you keep a secret, think about keeping a secret. You have to constantly monitor, right? When you're in a conversation where it could be relevant, you've got to be, you got to monitor your brain. And that's stressful. And so that literally can increase your cortisol, your stress hormones. It can affect you in this way. And it also, there have been lots of studies showing that when you are,
但事实上，这可能是一个极其活跃的过程。所以当你保守秘密时，想想保守秘密这件事。你必须时刻监控，对吧？当你在一段谈话中，而这个秘密可能与之相关时，你就得监控你的大脑。这压力太大了。所以这真的会增加你的皮质醇、你的压力荷尔蒙。它会以这种方式影响你。而且还有很多研究表明，当你
keeping a secret, you score lower on IQ tests because it literally preoccupies your brain. It takes away brain space. You talk about one of the costs of self-concealment is that it can keep us from forming relationships or deepening relationships. You tell the story of a, perhaps a trivial encounter in an elevator when you were a young scholar on the job market. Tell me that story, Leslie. Yeah. So one of the the principles that's really important in new relationships, new friendships, new acquaintances new romances is mutual self-disclosure. It's like a ping-pong pattern of reciprocity where you say something, the other person reciprocates with something just as deep. You don't start super deep. You start maybe on a more shallow, but then you go back and forth, ping-pong,
保守秘密时，你在智商测试中的得分会降低，因为它确实占据了你的大脑，占用了你的脑力空间。你提到自我隐瞒的代价之一是，它会阻止我们建立人际关系或加深关系。你讲过一个故事，关于你在求职市场当青年学者时，在电梯里的一次微不足道的偶遇。给我讲讲那个故事吧，莱斯利。好的。新关系、新友谊、新认识、新恋情中非常重要的原则之一就是相互自我披露。这就像是一种乒乓球式的互惠模式：你说了一点，另一个人也会以同样深度的内容进行回应。你们不会一开始就聊得非常深。你们可能从比较浅的话题开始，然后你来我往，像打乒乓球一样，
back and forth and you get increasingly more vulnerable with each other. This comes back to even Arthur Aaron's studies, right? The 36 questions where you get people to ask and answer questions to each other and that makes them like each other and forge friendships. And so this encounter, this is what I call a reciprocity fail. When one person puts out an olive branch, they put themselves out there and then they're shut down. So what happened to me, I was trying to get an academic job. I was on an academic job market. I'm in my like banana republic black suit, which fun fact, after the fact, I realized I still had the stitching and the double vent in the back. The stitch, I had unstitched it. So rookie, so endearing. So in this rookie academic job market,
你来我往，彼此之间变得越来越脆弱、越来越坦诚。这甚至可以追溯到亚瑟·亚伦（Arthur Aron）的研究，对吧？那36个问题，让人们互相提问并回答问题，这能让他们互相喜欢并建立友谊。所以这次偶遇，就是我所说的“互惠失败”。当一个人伸出橄榄枝、敞开心扉，却被冷漠拒绝时。所以当时发生在我身上的事是，我正试图找一份学术工作。我在学术求职市场上。我穿着香蕉共和国（Banana Republic）的黑色西装，趣事是，事后我才发现，当时后面开衩的缝线我还没拆开。连线都没拆。所以是个新手，真是太讨人喜欢了。所以在这种初出茅庐的学术求职市场上，
what you do is there's a, is that a big hotel and all the different universities that are recruiting. They rent out different suites. And so every hour on the hour, there's this jamboree of rookie candidates moving from room to room to pitch themselves. So I found myself in the elevator. I get into the elevator and there's one, clearly a job candidate in there. The elevator doors close. So we're literally in a steel vault. And I say, I let my guard on. I just say, I'm so exhausted. My whole body just was like exuded exhaustion. And then what did the fellow job candidate do, he straightened right up and he said, oh, this is such an exciting and fun opportunity to get senior faculty to weigh in all of my research. It's so amazing. And then I like
你要做的是，在一个大酒店里，所有招聘的不同大学都会租用不同的套房。所以每到整点，就会有一场初出茅庐的求职者从一个房间涌向另一个房间去推销自己的狂欢。于是我发现自己在电梯里。我走进电梯，里面明显有一个求职者。电梯门关上了。所以我们 literalmente（字面意义上）在一个钢铁牢笼里。我说，我放松了戒备。我只是说：我太累了。我的整个身体都散发着精疲力竭的气息。然后另一个求职者做了什么？他立刻挺直身子说：哦，这可是一个令人兴奋和开心的大好机会，能让资深教员来对我的所有研究进行评审。这太棒了。然后我用整个身体
gave him the stink guy with my whole body. I just was like, in my mind, what I thought is like, really, we're literally in a steel vault. And you can't, we can't just be real, like have a real moment of kind of shared feeling that would make us both feel more relaxed. And, you know, it's interesting, this idea that a reciprocity, the sting of a reciprocity failure lingers, because we see each other regularly at conferences. He's very accomplished. And I'm sure he's a really nice guy. But I've never felt the urge to like go chat him up. And I think I think I would attribute it to that. In other words, you basically, you know, you put yourself out there. He declined. And the point that you're making is not just that you didn't have an exchange in that elevator for 30
给了他一个白眼。我当时心里想的是：真的吗？我们 literalmente 在一个钢铁牢笼里，难道我们不能真实一点，来一个能让我们俩都感到更放松的、共同感受的真实瞬间吗？你知道，这很有趣，互惠失败带来的刺痛感会挥之不去，因为我们在学术会议上经常见到彼此。他非常有成就。我确信他是个很好的人。但我从来没有想去跟他寒暄的冲动。我想，我想这可以归咎于那次经历。换句话说，你基本上，你知道的，你敞开了心扉。而他拒绝了。你提出的观点不仅是你们在那部电梯里没有进行30秒的交流，
seconds, but in some ways it's had ramifications. You know, it's echoed, if you will, down the years where you actually haven't tried to make a connection with it. Exactly. And so imagine if we play the other route of, imagine if he had reciprocated and been like, I know, I just had this crazy interview. Can you believe it? This person said that or blah, blah, blah, blah. Like a moment, a moment like that. Imagine we could have been lifelong friends. So many of us, I think, into it that self-concealment has costs, Leslie. And many of us I think intuit what those costs are. But one reason we hide is that we believe that we alone harbor shameful secrets. Talk about this idea that when it comes to the
而且在某种程度上，这产生了后续影响。你知道的，它甚至在岁月中产生了回响，以至于你实际上再也没有尝试过去跟他建立联系。完全正确。所以想象一下，如果我们走另一条路——想象如果他做出了回应，并说：我懂，我刚刚经历了一场疯狂的面试。你敢相信吗？这人说了那样的话，巴拉巴拉巴拉。就像那样的一个瞬间。想象一下，我们可能会成为终身的朋友。我想我们中的很多人都直觉到自我隐瞒是有代价的，莱斯利。而且我想我们中的很多人都能直觉到这些代价是什么。但我们隐瞒的原因之一是，我们相信只有我们自己怀有那些见不得人的秘密。聊聊这种想法：当涉及到
things that we hold secret, we somehow imagine that we are the only ones holding those secrets. Yeah. So I think a big reason is that secrets are not visible. We don't see all of the secrets that people are holding, it makes us feel like we're the only ones that hold secrets, which makes them even more kind of clandestine, right? And they take an even bigger toll on this. It's interesting. Michael Slepian over at Columbia has done, and Malia Mason, they've done some really great work on a questionnaire to find out what people's common secrets are. And it turns out that there are Lots of things that people tend to keep secret.
我们保守的秘密时，我们不知为何总是想象只有我们自己才怀有这些秘密。是的。所以我觉得一个主要原因是秘密是不可见的。我们看不到人们保守的所有秘密，这让我们觉得自己是唯一保守秘密的人，这让它们变得更加隐秘，对吧？并且它们为此付出了更大的代价。这很有趣。哥伦比亚大学的迈克尔·斯莱皮安（Michael Slepian）和马利亚·梅森（Malia Mason）做了一些非常出色的工作，他们通过问卷调查来找出人们常见的秘密是什么。结果发现，有
It's a very normal thing. I'm wondering if social media in some ways compounds this, because now we not only don't hear our people's secrets, but we're constantly being presented, this view of other people's lives that's always glamorous and excited and people having a great time at fancy restaurants. And now we feel, well, clearly the fact that I'm eating, you know, a reheated dinner from three days ago,
很多事情是人们倾向于保守秘密的。这是一件非常正常的事情。我在想，社交媒体在某种程度上是否加剧了这一点，因为现在我们不仅听不到别人的秘密，而且我们不断被展示这样一种对他人生活的看法：永远光鲜亮丽，永远令人兴奋，人们在高档餐厅里过得很开心。现在我们觉得：好吧，很明显，我居然在吃三天前加热的剩饭，
it must show that I'm the only one who has this dirty secret, everyone else is having a grand old time. Right, exactly. Social media is so toxic for that reason. It's, it's, it's, it's exactly as you said, people present a curated portrait of themselves. And logically we know this, but we cannot, we have a hard time correcting for it, the visceral feeling. You see someone who looks gorgeous with their perfect children in their perfect life and you think, oh my God, meanwhile, my children are screaming. And so it makes you feel badly about yourself, these, these kinds of comparisons. When we come back, Leslie comes up with a survey asking people if they have ever cheated on their taxes, watched pornography, or called in sick when they wanted to spend a day at the beach. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Can you think of a secret you haven't shared with anyone? How does keeping the secret make you feel?
这肯定说明我才是唯一怀有这个肮脏秘密的人，其他所有人都在过着宏大美好的生活。没错，完全如此。社交媒体正是因为这个原因才如此有毒。它，正如你所说的那样，人们展示的是自己经过精心策划的形象。从逻辑上讲我们知道这一点，但我们很难去纠正它，很难克服那种内心深处的直观感受。你看到某人带着完美的孩子过着完美的生活，看起来光彩照人，然后你心里想：哦，天哪，与此同时我的孩子还在尖叫。所以这些，这些类型的比较会让你对自己的感觉很糟糕。稍后回来，莱斯利会拿出一份调查问卷，询问人们是否曾逃过税、看黄色录影带、或者在想去海滩度过一天时谎称生病请假。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你能想起一个你没有跟任何人分享过的秘密吗？保守这个秘密让你感觉如何？
What do you think would happen if you shared the secret with others? If you're willing to share your personal story with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, secrets. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Psychologist Leslie John is the author of Revealing,
如果你把这个秘密分享给别人，你觉得会发生什么？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录下一条语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将音频文件发送至我们的邮箱：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：secrets。再重复一遍，邮箱是：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。心理学家莱斯利·约翰是《大白话：过度分享被低估的力量》一书的作者。
the underrated power of oversharing. Leslie, as you dived into the world of embarrassing disclosures, you and an advisor once came up with survey questions. This turned out to be a very challenging exercise. How so? I think I might hold the world record for the most awkward doctoral advisor-advised conversation. So when I was a doctoral student,
莱斯利，当你深入令人尴尬的秘密披露的世界时，你和一位导师曾想出了一些调查问题。事实证明，这是一个极具挑战性的练习。怎么说呢？我想我可能保持着“最尴尬的博士生与导师对话”的世界纪录。当我还是个博士生的时候，
I've been interested in this topic of revealing privacy, self-disclosure secrets for a very long time now. And so when I was a doctoral student, I worked with my advisor to devise a series of surveys where we asked people sensitive questions and we varied different things to learn different things. And so we needed to come up with really sensitive things to ask people. And so we sat in his office. It's one of these like flashbulb memories for me.
我对展现隐私、自我披露秘密这个话题已经感兴趣很长时间了。所以当我是个博士生时，我和我的导师设计了一系列调查，在调查中我们向人们询问敏感问题，并通过改变不同的条件来了解不同的事情。因此，我们需要想出真正敏感的事情来问人们。于是我们坐在他的办公室里。这对我来说是那种闪光灯记忆之一。
You know, you remember exactly what you were wearing and where you was seated. Yeah, so he just starts with the bang. He says, what about bestiality? Oh, man. And so, yeah, I was like, the person that I'm most trying to impress said that. And so I was like, what do I do? Do I go for something super sensitive like that? In my, the things that I bring to the table brainstorming, I felt like everything I said then was like, maybe he's going to think I'm a prude or. Or then if I said something really bad, like, have you ever neglected to tell a partner about an SDD you had? Then he'd think I was reckless. And just even the thought of that I am worrying about my advisor. Like, it just, oh, gosh, it was so cringy. But we got through it. We powered through.
你知道的，你清楚地记得自己当时穿什么衣服，坐在哪里。对，所以他开门见山。他说：兽交怎么样？哦，天哪。然后，对，我当时心想：我最想给他留下深刻印象的人竟然说出了这个。所以我就想：我该怎么办？我要选择像那样超级敏感的事情吗？在我提出的头脑风暴内容中，我觉得我当时说的一切都会让他觉得我是个保守的伪君子。或者如果我说了一些真的很糟糕的话，比如：你有没有对伴侣隐瞒过你曾得过性病？那他就会觉得我很鲁莽。仅仅是想到我在担心导师对我的看法——这真是，哦天哪，太让人尴尬了。但我们熬过来了。我们硬着头皮撑过去了。
And we came up with a great list. And I've since been using those questions and variations on those themes for kind of my career so far. So the survey took the form of questions that start with, have you ever? I'm wondering if you can read out a list of these questions, Leslie, and I want listeners to ask themselves if they have ever done any of these things. Okay. So, yeah, the questions, be warned, they're doozies. If you have children around.
我们想出了一份很棒的清单。从那以后，我一直在我的职业生涯中沿用这些问题以及这些主题的变体。所以调查的形式是以“你曾……吗？”开头的问题。莱斯利，我想知道你能否宣读这份问题清单，我想让听众们问问自己是否做过其中任何事情。好的。所以，这些问题，请注意，都是重磅炸弹。如果你周围有小孩子的话……
Have you ever had sex with the current husband, wife, or partner of a friend? Have you ever had a fantasy of doing something? terrible, e.g. torturing to someone? Have you ever stolen anything worth more than $100? Have you ever looked at pornographic material? Have you ever made a false insurance claim? Have you ever cheated on your tax return? Have you ever claimed to have education that you didn't actually have? While in a relationship, have you ever flirted with somebody other than your partner? Have you ever taken credit for someone else's work? Have you ever let a friend drive after you thought he or she had too much to drink? Have you ever lied about your income to someone? Have you ever called in sick when you
你是否曾与朋友的现任丈夫、妻子或伴侣发生过性关系？你是否曾幻想过做某件可怕的事情，例如：折磨某人？你是否曾偷过价值超过100美元的东西？你是否曾观看过色情材料？你是否曾提出过虚假的保险索赔？你是否曾在纳税申报表上作假？你是否曾宣称自己拥有实际上并没有的学历？在恋爱关系中，你是否曾对伴侣以外的人调情？你是否曾将别人的劳动成果据为己有？你是否曾在一个朋友喝得太多之后，还让他/她开车？你是否曾向任何人谎报过你的收入？当你……时，你是否曾谎称生病请假？
Have you ever pretended not to see a beggar to avoid being seen as stingy? Have you ever gone on a date only to make somebody else jealous? Have you ever drunk so much that you got a hangover? Have you ever littered in a public space? Have you ever failed to do chores in a shared house or apartment? And have you ever failed to tip a waiter in a country in which tipping is customary? These are the questions. And these I've more or less said them in a decreasing order of sensitivity.
你是否曾假装没看到乞丐以避免被视为吝啬？你是否曾为了让别人嫉妒而约会？你是否曾喝到宿醉？你是否曾在公共场所乱扔垃圾？你是否曾在合租的房子或公寓里不干家务？你是否曾在习惯给小费的国家里不给服务员小费？这些就是问题。我或多或少是以敏感度递减的顺序念出这些问题的。
I'm sure people must clam up if someone asked them this question in a research setting. that's what I would think too. But again and again, like across all of the research I've done, the one thing that really surprises me is how forthcoming people often are. It almost seems like people really want to reveal. And in fact, there's been subsequent research showing that we do have this kind of internal drive to reveal. And it's fascinating because there's even, some of these things are even illegal. Now, the way we asked matters, right? So if we had asked face to face in an interrogation room. I don't know that people would be forthcoming.
我敢肯定，如果有人在研究环境中问人们这个问题，他们肯定会三缄其口。我以前也是这么想的。但一次又一次，在我做过的所有研究中，真正让我惊讶的是人们往往是多么坦诚。这几乎看起来人们真的很想倾诉。事实上，后续的研究表明，我们确实有这种内在的倾诉驱动力。这很着迷，因为其中甚至有一些事情甚至是违法的。现在，我们提问的方式很重要，对吧？所以，如果我们是在审讯室里面对面地问。我不知道人们是否会这么坦诚。
But the way we asked these, we asked it on a pseudo-anonymous online survey, so it was done in the comfort of your home. You don't have someone staring there watching you, judging you. In one set of studies, Leslie has examined whether people think less of those who have revealed unsavory things about themselves. Obviously, the answer is yes, right? Not necessarily. which is pretty shocking. So what we did in this study was we asked people, let's say, we asked,
但我们提问的方式是，我们在一个半匿名的在线调查中询问的，所以它是在你舒适的家中完成的。没有人在那里盯着你看、评判你。在一组研究中，莱斯利探讨了人们是否会对那些透露自己令人讨厌的事情的人产生不好的看法。显然，答案是肯定的，对吧？不一定。这相当令人震惊。所以我们在这项研究中所做的是，我们问人们，比方说，我们问，
who would you rather hire? And candidate A, one of the questions they had been asked on this intake survey was, have you ever been reprimanded at work? Yes, no, choose not to answer. We, of course, constructed these profiles ourselves. So candidate A, to the question, have you ever been reprimanded at work says yes, just goes out and says the worst thing. Candidate B, on the other hand, clicked the choose not to answer box. So here we have a choice. The participants had a choice. Would you prefer someone who admits something bad that they've been reprimanded at work to someone who simply but very conspicuously refrains from answering, says, I'm not telling you, I'm opting out, I'm concealing, essentially. And it turns out that again and again, people prefer the review.
你更愿意雇佣谁？对于候选人A，他们在这次入职调查中被问到的问题之一是，你曾在工作中被训诫过吗？是，否，选择不回答。我们当然是自己构建了这些 profiles。因此，对于“你曾在工作中被训诫过吗”这个问题，候选人A回答“是”，直接把最糟糕的事情说了出来。另一方面，候选人B点击了“选择不回答”的方框。所以这里我们有一个选择。参与者有一个选择。你更愿意选择一个承认自己做过坏事、曾在工作中被训诫过的人，还是选择一个只是非常显眼地拒绝回答、说“我不会告诉你、我选择退出、本质上在隐瞒”的人？事实证明，一次又一次，人们更倾向于选择那个坦白的人。
They prefer the person who admits to the thing, even if it's a bad thing, relative to someone who opts out of answering, who very saliently says, I'm not doing this. In fact, you find something along the same lines when it comes to romantic relationships as well. Yes, so we did this. The first time we got these results, we thought, is this a false positive? This is Nutty noodle, as my late grandmother would say. But so we did it, again with other questions, other samples, other scenarios. And one of the ones we tried was in the realm of dating, where what we did was we asked people, which of these two people would you prefer to date? Person A or person B? And one of the questions was, have you ever filed a false
他们更喜欢那个承认事情的人，即使这是一件坏事，而不是选择那些拒绝回答、非常明显地表示“我才不干这事”的人。事实上，当你谈到恋爱关系时，也会发现类似的情况。是的，我们做了这个。我们第一次得到这些结果时，我们在想，这是不是一个假阳性？正如我已故的祖母常说的那样，这真是太荒谬了。所以我们又做了一次，用了其他问题、其他样本、其他情景。我们尝试过的情景之一是在约会领域，我们所做的是询问人们，这两个人中你更愿意和谁约会？A或B？其中一个问题是，你是否曾提交过虚假的
insurance claim? And person A ostensibly has said frequently. So they're saying the worst possible thing. The other person, person B, has clicked choose not to answer. And again and again, people, they'd rather date someone. Now, neither of these is fine specimens. My father used to always say that. That's a fine specimen. Yeah, neither of them are someone you want to take home to your parents. But if push came to shove, right? If you're in this tight bind, which would you choose? Because that's deeply revealing of human nature behind it. And again and again, we prefer the revealer. And what do you think this is telling us? Why is it? Why is it? that we are so averse to the hider, even when the only option is a revealer who tells us that
保险索赔？表面上看，A经常这样做。所以他们说的是可能的最糟糕的事情。另一个人，B，点击了“选择不回答”。一次又一次，人们宁愿和这样的人约会。现在，这两个都不是什么完美的标本。我父亲过去常这么说。那是个完美的标本。是的，他们都不是你想带回家见父母的人。但如果非要做出选择，对吧？如果你陷入这种困境，你会选哪个？因为这深深地揭示了背后的的人性。一次又一次，我们更喜欢那个坦白的人。你觉得这在告诉我们什么？为什么，为什么？我们如此反感隐瞒者，即使唯一的选择是一个告诉我们
they have done something wrong? Yeah, it's a great question. And we did many, many studies to try to understand why this was happening and why it was not happening. In the end, what we discovered was that the preference for a revealer is driven by a global character judgment. The person who conceals is not to be trusted. So much so that we'd rather date someone, we'd rather employ someone, we'd rather even sit next to the subway beside someone who comes clean, even if it's not the greatest thing to say. So researchers have found that several cognitive biases shape our desire to conceal. One of them is called the impact bias. What is the impact bias, Leslie? Yeah, so the impact bias is
他们做错了事的坦白者？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们做了很多很多研究，试图理解为什么会发生这种情况，以及为什么没有发生这种情况。最后，我们发现，人们对坦白者的偏爱是由一种全球性格判断驱动的。隐瞒的人是不值得信任的。以至于我们宁愿和坦白的人约会，宁愿雇用坦白的人，甚至宁愿坐在地铁里挨着一个坦白的人，即使这不是什么好听的话。因此，研究人员发现，几种认知偏差塑造了我们隐瞒的欲望。其中之一被称为影响偏差。什么是影响偏差，莱斯利？是的，影响偏差是
how we tend to overestimate the longevity of emotional. events. So we think that when we break up with someone or if someone breaks up with us, we think we're going to be down in the dumps for a very, very long time slash eternity. When reality, when that happens, like we're often surprised to see like, yeah, it sucks, but we're better sooner than we think. Similarly, we think the highs last longer than they do. Like, you know, we get a raise. We think we'll be like feeling amazing for a really long time. But that we quickly adapt and it quickly subsides. So the impact bias refers to how we overestimate the duration and intensity of emotional events. The impact bias ends up shaping what we regret and also the difference between short-term regrets and long-term regrets.
我们倾向于高估情绪事件持久性的方式。所以我们认为，当我们与某人分手，或者如果有人与我们分手，我们认为我们会情绪低落非常非常长的时间，甚至直到永远。而现实是，当这种情况发生时，我们常常惊讶地发现，是的，这很糟糕，但我们恢复得比想象的要快。同样，我们认为快乐的时光比实际更长。比如，你知道，我们加薪了。我们以为我们会感觉好得不得了，持续很长时间。但我们很快就会适应，这种感觉很快就会消退。因此，影响偏差是指我们如何高估情绪事件的持续时间和强度。影响偏差最终塑造了我们的遗憾，也塑造了短期遗憾与长期遗憾之间的区别。
In one study, the psychologist Thomas Gilevich and Victoria Medvec explored this difference. It's really fascinating because what they found was that in the short run, we tend to regret the things we did that resulted in bad outcomes, so-called sins of commission. So in disclosure language, it's, it's, you say something, maybe you're a little tipsy, you say something, you feel like you go a little bit too far at a dinner party. The next morning you have a massive disclosure hangover where you're that gut wrenching, oh, why did I do that? And you just want to hide.
在一项研究中，心理学家托马斯·吉洛维奇和维多利亚·梅德韦克探讨了这种区别。这真的很有趣，因为他们发现，在短期内，我们倾向于遗憾那些导致不良结果的事情，即所谓的“不作为之罪”。用披露的语言来说，就是，你说了些什么，也许你有点微醺，你说了些什么，你觉得在晚宴上有点说得太过分了。第二天早上，你会有严重的“披露宿醉”，那种揪心的“我为什么要那样做”的感觉，你只想躲起来。
And that sucks. And so we regret that a lot. So in the short run, right after we regret the things we do, the regrettable things that we did. But in the long run, the pattern flips such that what we end up regretting much more over the course of our lives, the things that we didn't do, the sins of omission, the things that we didn't do that we should have done. Those are the things that leave us thinking, what if, what if I had told my college crush that I was into him? Like, what if I, why didn't I do that? What would it be the harm?
这太糟糕了。所以我们对此感到非常遗憾。因此，在短期内，就在事情发生后，我们对我们所做的事情、我们所做的令人遗憾的事情感到遗憾。但在长期内，这种模式会发生逆转，在我们的整个生活中，我们最终遗憾得多的事情，是我们没有做的事情，即“不作为之罪”，那些我们本该做却没有做的事情。这些事情让我们不禁去想，如果……如果我告诉我暗恋的大学同学我喜欢他，会怎样？如果我……我为什么不那样做？会有什么害处？
And what are the missed opportunities? Meanwhile, we don't ruminate at all over the long haul about, okay, maybe I, maybe I was rebuffed by this person. But at least I found out, you know, you get kind of closure and you don't continue perseverating. There was a book by the hospice care nurse Brony Ware titled The Top Five Regrets of the Dining. What were these regrets, Leslie? Yes. So, Brony Ware, my hero, she has. has spent as a palliative care nurse, she spent time a lot of time with people at the very end of
还有那些错失的机会？与此同时，从长远来看，我们根本不会去反思，好吧，也许我，也许我被这个人拒绝了。但至少我弄清了真相，你知道的，你得到了一种释怀，而不会继续纠结。临终关怀护士布罗妮·韦尔写过一本书，书名叫《临终前最后悔的五件事》。这些遗憾是什么，莱斯利？是的。所以，布罗妮·韦尔，我的偶像，她花了。作为一名姑息治疗护士，她花了很多时间陪伴那些处于人生
their lives. So she gets to know them a lot. And she wrote a book where she collated her observations on what people tended to regret. So on their dying beds, what did they say they regret? And here are the top five regrets. I wish I'd had the courage to live a life true to myself, not the life others expected of me. Number two, I wish I hadn't worked so hard. Number three, I wish I'd had the courage to express my feelings. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. Number four, I wish I had stayed in touch with my friends. Number five, I wish I had let myself be happier. And so you can see, four out of five of them are regret over things we didn't do that we wish we had done. And one of them especially is that is one related to not sharing more of ourselves, not expressing our feelings.
最后阶段的人们。所以她对他们有了很多了解。她写了一本书，在书中整理了她对人们往往会感到遗憾的事情的观察。所以在临终病榻上，他们说他们最后悔的是什么？以下是最后悔的五件事。第一，我希望我有勇气过真正忠于自己的生活，而不是别人期望的生活。第二，我希望我没有那么拼命工作。第三，我希望我有勇气表达自己的感情。叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。第四，我希望我能和朋友保持联系。第五，我希望我能让自己更快乐。所以你可以看到，五分之四的遗憾都是关于我们没有做、但希望自己曾做过的事情。其中有一项尤其与没有更多地分享自己、没有表达我们的感情有关。
You say that you yourself were inspired to engage in more self-disclosure by Bronny Ware's book. Tell me about a recent incident with your mother, where in some ways you were made aware, if you will, of all the things that you hadn't told her. Oh, geez, yeah, this was a scary episode. It was, it was Christmas Day. And my husband and I had just finished spending a lot of the day cooking in the kitchen thanks to grandparents who took care of our little boys. And we were putting the turkey on the table and my mom looks gaunt. She says, I'm really not feeling well. Something's just come over me. I got to go lie down. So she went to go lie down. We serve the stuff and then I go upstairs to find her and I find her in the bathroom
你说你自己受到布罗妮·韦尔书的启发，从而进行了更多的自我披露。跟我讲讲最近发生在你母亲身上的事吧，在某种程度上，这件事让你意识到，如果你愿意这么说的话，所有那些你没有告诉她的事情。哦，天哪，是的，这是一个可怕的插曲。当时是圣诞节。我和丈夫刚刚在厨房里花了很多时间做饭，多亏了祖父母帮忙照顾我们的小男孩。当我们把火鸡端上桌时，我妈妈看起来很憔悴。她说：“我真的感觉很不舒服。有什么东西突然涌上来了。我得去躺一会儿。”于是她去躺下了。我们把东西端上桌，然后我上楼去找她，发现她在卫生间里，
clearly having vomited and looking at me with this glazed look of like unclear who I was. And so I grabbed her and I held her in my arms like a baby. And as soon as I did that, her eyes rolled back in her head and she went limp. And I thought that she had died in my arms. and I just, I sprang up and I bolted out the door. I said, call 911. My husband's calling 911. I bolt out the door to our neighbor, who's a nurse.
显然吐了，看着我时眼神呆滞，好像认不出我是谁了。所以我抓住她，像抱婴儿一样把她抱在怀里。我一这么做，她的双眼就往上翻，身体瘫软了下来。我以为她死在了我的怀里。我一下子跳起来，冲向门外。我说：“快叫911。”我丈夫在叫911。我冲出门，去找我们的邻居，她是一名护士。
And I bang, bang, I'm banging on their windows. And she comes and right away, she runs in. And then we get to the bathroom where my mom was. And my mom looks at us like, what's all the fuss about? What are you doing? I'm fine. She was fine. It turned out that she, we think it was food poisoning.
我砰砰地敲着他们的窗户。她来了，马上跑了进去。然后我们来到了我妈妈所在的卫生间。我妈妈看着我们，好像在说：“大惊小怪什么？你们在干什么？我很好。”她没事。事实证明，我们认为那是食物中毒。
And apparently when you vomit so violently, it can disrupt what's called your vagus nerve, which like overstimulates it. And either way you need to kind of reset your brain by passing out. That's my layperson version of it. But, oh my gosh, that was so terrifying. But it really, it really reminded. Like my mother at the time was 70. super spry. She's still super spry. It really reminded me that, I know it's cliche to say, but it's so true that you never know when your time is coming. And so with disclosure, what that means is that
显然，当你呕吐得如此剧烈时，它会打乱所谓的迷走神经，这就像过度刺激了它。无论如何，你需要通过昏厥来重置你的大脑。这是我这个外行的版本。但是，天哪，太可怕了。但这真的，真的提醒了我。就像我母亲当时70岁一样。超级敏捷。她现在依然超级敏捷。它真的提醒了我，我知道说这是老生常谈，但事实确实如此，你永远不知道你的死期何时到来。所以对于披露来说，这意味着
like, don't hold back. Don't hold back telling someone all the ways you love them. And so I ended up writing this love list, this list of things to my mom about all the ways I love her. and all the big things and all the little things. Yeah, it was really important to me. Did you read the letter to her or did you give her the letter? I put it in her stocking. And it had all kinds of things in it like big things, for example, I'm so grateful and I love the way she and my father,
不要有所保留。不要吝啬告诉某人你爱他们的所有方式。所以我最后写了这张“爱的清单”，这是给我妈妈的一张清单，列出了我爱她的所有方式，包括所有的大事和小事。是的，这对我真的很重要。你把这封信读给她听了，还是把信交给她了？我把它塞进了她的袜子里。里面有各种各样的事情，比如大事，例如，我很感激，我喜欢她和我父亲相处的方式，
they always, I mean, we are very lucky in that we had, you know, we weren't wealthy, but we definitely were comfortable. And so we were in a privileged position to be able to pursue our interests. And my parents really, really encouraged that, they said, always pursue what you're interested. And I feel that I got to this amazing place called Harvard doing what I love doing because fundamentally, you know, I worked hard, but I pursued my interest. And I got a lot of luck in all those other things. But the kind of life, the important life lessons I'm so grateful for. And then the small stuff too, like, oh, I love how she, this, oh my gosh, she, so I love gummy candies and what my, but I'm very particular on the colors. I like the green
他们总是，我的意思是，我们非常幸运，我们拥有，你知道的，我们并不富有，但我们的生活绝对很舒适。所以我们处于一个有特权的地位，能够追求我们的兴趣。我的父母真的、真的很鼓励这一点，他们说，永远去追求你感兴趣的事。我觉得我做着自己喜欢的事，走到了哈佛这个了不起的地方，因为从根本上说，你知道的，我很努力，但我追求了我的兴趣。我在所有这些其他事情上运气很好。但我非常感激那些人生中重要的一课。还有那些小事，哦，我喜欢她，这个，哦天哪，她，我喜欢软糖，而且我对颜色非常挑剔。我喜欢绿色
ones, if they're lime, not apple. And I love the red ones. And so when she comes to visit us, she gives me a bag of jujub's gummy bears with curated just the colors I like. She picks out the ones I don't and eats the drags and then she gives her daughter, like, oh, yeah. It's amazing. In our episode next week, we continue our exploration of the power of self-disclosure. Look for the episode titled Coming Clean. We also look at when and where the scientific evidence suggests it may be best to withhold information and to play your cards close to the chest.
的那种，如果是青柠味的，不要苹果味的。我喜欢红色的。所以当她来探望我们时，她会给我带一包朱朱熊软糖，里面全是我喜欢的颜色。她挑出我不喜欢的那些，把边角料吃掉，然后给她女儿，哦，太棒了。在下周的节目中，我们将继续探讨自我披露的力量。敬请收听题为《彻底坦白》的节目。我们还将探讨科学证据表明何时以及何地最好隐瞒信息并把底牌藏在心里。
That's in our Hidden Brain Plus episode titled When to Hide the Truth. If you're a subscriber, that episode should be available in your podcast feed right now. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co.com slash hidden brain. Again, that's support.com.hiddenbrain.org and Apple.com slash hidden brain. Leslie John is a psychologist at Harvard University. She's the author of Revealing the underrated power of oversharing. Leslie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
这是我们的《隐秘大脑Plus》节目，题为《何时隐藏真相》。如果你是订阅者，该节目现在应该可以在你的播客动态中收听。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.co.com/hidden brain。再次强调，网址是support.com.hiddenbrain.org和Apple.com/hidden brain。莱斯利·约翰是哈佛大学的心理学家。她是《揭秘：过度分享的被低估的力量》一书的作者。莱斯利，非常感谢你今天加入我的节目《隐秘大脑》。
It's been a delight. Thank you. Can you think of a time when you came clean to someone else? Do you remember what happened and how it felt? If you are willing to share your personal story with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.org. Use the subject line, Secrets.
这真是太高兴了。谢谢你。你能想起什么时候你对别人坦白过吗？你还记得发生了什么以及当时的感觉吗？如果你愿意与《隐秘大脑》的听众分享你的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。请使用主题行：秘密。
Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please tell your friends about it,
再次强调，邮箱是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·克雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢这期节目，请告诉你的朋友，
in person or on social media. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以当面告诉他们，也可以在社交媒体上分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。